hi there kevin o'leary your investor at
large in the most unusual place you can
imagine we're sitting here at the
epicenter of the imaginal line you
probably forgot your history this is a
very very famous line built by the
French after they first defeated the
Germans in the First World War but the
deal they cut with them afterwards was
so owner us against the Germans they
made the assumption that eventually the
Germans would want retaliation and
attacked them so they built this
incredible line all along the border of
France and Germany and this is one of
the forts schulenburg here this is a
remarkable facility a massive 1000 meter
bunker with some of the largest
artillery ever made in the 30s and it's
an incredible place to visit you have to
walk a long way to see the gunnery but
it's really quite something it defended
this whole area they could shoot the
shells nine kilometres but what does
this have to do with investing well
here's what I find so interesting is an
investor think about this they spent all
that time and money trying to keep the
Germans out of France and now what do
they want the Germans back into France
because they want their money the
eurozone depends on the German economy
now this tells you something as an
investment so important there are no
permanent friends and there are no
permanent enemies they're just permanent
interests and what is that money it's
always about the money all of the time
and you know it now from the imagino
line until next time your investor at
large kevin O'Leary